brand collaborations used to be sparing
targeted special even but now we see a
feeding frenzy of tactical virality
based on one magic symbol balmain and
barbie sure zara are never last why not
verve klico and yayoi
come on in the clicks are lovely no
collaboration is too kooky no
partnership too wacky in this patchwork
harlow grenade but why do brands
collaborate the most obvious answer is
the magic that happens when brands
co-mingle fans
when taco bell joined forces with
frito-lay they sold a billion dollars of
doritos locos tacos in 14 months
similarly the collab artois between
yeezy gap and balenciaga created a
presence far greater than the sum of its
already great parts much of this is
driven by media and social media for
whom collaborations are catnip
especially when it's startling as liquid
desk skateboards painted with tony
hawk's blood and then there is the
network effect exemplified by james bond
product placements where middle level
brands like toyota and heineken bask in
the glory not just of double 07 but of
luxury marks like aston martin and
bollinger
how brands collaborate is equally
fascinating there are the high low
collaborations popularized in the 90s by
target which created mastice collections
with everyone from missoni to victoria
beckham there are strawberries and cream
collaborations when say nike supplies
their shoes but apple tracks the steps
or when red bull provides the energy but
gopro captures the proof
there are taste bud collaborations that
monkey with our senses like coffee mate
and snickers or coca-cola tic tacs
there are digital divide collaborations
where analog brands join with next-gen
tech like gucci and xbox or esalaron and
google there are beach head
collaborations that introduce new
shampoos to unsuspecting hotel guests or
tempt fast food carnivores to experiment
with plant-based proteins and finally
there are shock before collaborations
championed by supreme which seems to be
on a quasi-perotic quest to see if there
is anything it can co-brand that won't
sell out in seconds
collaborations are going nowhere not
just because they add to the gayety of
nations but because they work the
cleverest and most viral collaborations
don't really add value they multiply it
and this is why of all the characters on
the keyboard this cross may be
branding's most lucrative
the collaboration leads to fascination
which in turn leads on to cash
i'm ben sharp the branding and
advertising columnist for bloomberg
opinion
you